le conseil des impôts a remis son
rapport au président de la république
pour une réforme de la fiscalité sur les
revenus
parmi les mesures préconisées la retenue
à la source une méthode qui applique la
plupart des pays européens mais qui
semble très difficile d'applications en
france véronique auger ouvrir les
enveloppes sortir les déclarations de
revenus les agrafes et les méthodes de
fisc sont encore archaïque à l'image de
l'impôt français sur le revenu le
verdict du conseil des impôts est sans
appel
d'abord notre système est trop compliqué
chaque année les ministres des finances
concocte de nouveaux allègements barème
et autres trouvailles qui s'ajoute aux
précédentes
ensuite notre système est injuste 5% des
foyers acquittent cinquante deux pour
cent de l'impôt sur le revenu enfin
notre système est totalement différent
de ceux appliqués dans les principaux
pays européens il faudrait donc tout
revoir en grande bretagne l'impôt est
prélevé à la source ce sont les
entreprises qui au vu des salaires et de
la situation familiale effectué le
prélèvement sur la feuille de paie au
profit de l'état une formule que défend
le tout jeune comité national en faveur
d'une retenue à la source si
effectivement toutes les fois qu'un
salaire aucun revenu est perçue il est
automatiquement amputé de la part qui
reviendra à la collectivité ça me parait
indolore et ça me parait comment
dirais-je simple simple sauf pour les
entreprises et pour le gouvernement les
entreprises estiment qu'elles ont déjà
assez de soucis actuellement pour ne pas
se mettre à percevoir en plus les impôts
à la place de l'état le premier ministre
lui est favorable à une retenue à la
source mais dit-on à matignon il est
surtout urgent d'attendre
il y a déjà assez de grands chantiers en
route pour l'année
[Musique]